in den frühen abendstunden bleibt von
den geräuschen der stadt nur noch ein
leises echo
[Musik]
wenn die auf dem platz steht eine
menschentraube sie haben stöcke und
steine ergriffen
warum all die gewalt damit
wie sonst sollen wir die verlogenheit
und korruption der regierung und die
untätigen beamten bekämpfen die unser
land zurückhaltend
es gibt doch fortschritt damit du wirst
du die augen öffnen durch unser eigenes
schaffen mit hilfe aus amerika
ich sehe nicht gut es in den
veränderungen unseres landes und die
anderen hier sehen es genauso
wir werden etwas gegen diese zustände
unternehmen ihr werdet schon sehen
wartet ihr nur
los
rek
diese us soldaten schießen auf die
irakische stadt mossul
es ist ihr dritter versucht die stadt
einzunehmen
zuerst von saddam
dann von der irakischen al kaida und nun
vom 1
sieht man die schlachten im kontext
eines größeren krieges erkennt man
muster
dieser verrückte im nahen osten strebt
nach einer muslimische fundamentalisten
revolution
wir sind nicht nur wegen des
benzinpreises
unser handeln wird die zukunft der welt
für die nächsten 100 jahre prägen
die usa griffen heute morgen gruppen im
zusammenhang mit bin laden
in der diktatur waren gefängnisse wie
abu ghraib symbole von tod und folter es
ist für unser land unerlässlich eine
truppe mit weiteren 30.000 mann nach
afghanistan zu schicken
neue taktiken sorgen für siege
generelle werden helden
dann geht etwas schief und eine neue
bedrohung entsteht
ich würde sie einfach wegbomben
das hier ist meine sichtweise dieses
krieges
wir haben nicht gewonnen sind nicht
dabei zu gewinnen und es noch intensiver
zu versuchen wird nichts verändern
[Musik]
wir haben invasion und besetzung
versucht staatsbildung
aufstandsbekämpfung
wir schlugen der schlange den kopf ab
wer glaubt es gäbe eine saubere einfache
militärische lösung seitens der usa ist
verblendet
dennoch steht diese illusion weiterhin
im mittelpunkt der us politik in der
region schon seit die regierung kater
bis zum heutigen tag
wir behalten das öl vergesst das nicht
wir wollen das öl behalten
45 millionen dollar im monat
ok auf geht's
[Musik]
ich wuchs in indiana auf meine eltern
waren veteranen des zweiten weltkriegs
ein katholisch konservative haushalt der
1950 er jahre in der landesmitte
an den patriotismus mit der muttermilch
auf
eine positive einstellung zum militär
und den kriegsdienst gehörte zum
patriotismus einfach dazu
nach der highschool war die
militärakademie west point eine
attraktive option also ging ich dorthin
das war auf dem höhepunkt des
vietnamkriegs
studenten protestieren gegen die
maßnahmen der regierung
meine klassenkameraden und ich wusste
dass wir ziemlich schnell im
kriegsgebiet zum einsatz kommen würden
wir dachten lieber nicht so sehr über
den krieg nach der schrecken des krieges
ging weiter und so schwand die
politische stabilität
das hirn in den leerlauf einsatz du
deine pflicht
wir hätten nach dem sinn des krieges
fragen sollen
ob wir gewinnen können
[Musik]
und wenn nicht was machen wir das
gut für die anstrengung
die stelle diese scheinbar radikalen
fragen bezüglich unseres engagements im
nahen osten nicht nun seit 30 jahren
ohne
erfolg
[Musik]
es heißt wenn wir einen mann auf den
mond senden können kann uns alles
gelingen
doch können wir unser energieproblem
rechtzeitig lösen fast die hälfte
unseres öls wird mittlerweile importiert
wir verbrauchen unsere unersetzlichen
ressourcen
[Musik]
denkt darüber nach
wenn wir der 1970 er jahre dachte man in
amerika die öl und gasvorräte in
nordamerika gingen rapide zurück
und droht jederzeit ein katastrophaler
mangel ein drastischer rückgang der
diesel und benzin versorgung des
mobilitätssektor aus der amerikanischen
bevölkerung tankstellen geben nur noch
38 lied haben alle wussten die
abhängigkeit der usa von ausländischem
öl würde zu nehmen
die wirtschaftliche gefahr ausländischen
öl es liegt darin dass die versorger
starten ihre preise erhöhen und uns
blockieren könnten
genau das geschah als amerika sich auf
die seite israels stellte in form eines
öl embargos von
die ölkrise führte zu einer massenpanik
ein regierungsausschuss beschloss einen
raffinierungspraktiken und
sie im auto nach den schlüsseln
[Musik]
lackiert
mich freut aber
werden gehen dunklen afrika
[Musik]
wir haben aktuell zustimmungswerte von
70 prozent für unsere bisherige arbeit
aber durch die energiepolitik werden wir
zehn oder 15 prozent verlieren ich kann
aber ein wenig beliebtheit auch fan um
die krise zu bewältigen die uns in ein
paar jahren so oder so ins haus steht
wenn uns die energie ausgeht
die stimmen auch im weißen haus ist
ruhig fast schon an wichtig an diesem
wichtigen tag für präsident jimmy carter
er wird mal seine rede heute abend einen
theoretischen rahmen für die lösung der
energie und wirtschaftsprobleme des
landes vorlegen
guten abend ich
muss mit ihnen über eine grundlegende
gefahr für die amerikanische demokratie
reden
sie wird die einheit unserer nation
unmittelbar auf die probe stellen
da wir energiesicherheit brauchen
ersuche ich um den größten beitrag an
finanzen und ressourcen zu
friedenszeiten in der geschichte unseres
landes
damit wir amerikas andere kraftstoff
quellen ausbauen können kohle ölschiefer
pflanzen für gaza
unkonventionelle gas quellen und die
sonne
es war eine sehr durchdachte rede
rückblickend sehen wir dass wir diesen
weg jedoch nicht einschlugen
wir wollten uns von der wachsenden
abhängigkeit von ausländischem öl lösen
und so das volk werden dass hier sein
soll kommen ein tugendhaftes fallen
mit gottes hilfe
müssen wir einander zum wohle unserer
nation die hand reichen
[Musik]
ministerpräsident angeblich sieht ihr
plan die aufgabe freiwilliger
schutzmaßnahme
könnte dies zu einer allgemeinen
erhöhung der landesweiten benzinsteuer
führen
sein vorschlag im sommer 1979 wurde klar
abgelehnt
er will dass ihm die bevölkerung
amerikas vertrauen schenkt doch sie
hören ihm nicht zu
er hat doch nichts gesagt
das amerikanische volk damals wie heute
will den gürtel nicht enger schnüren sie
wollen nicht wenige haben sondern mehr
[Musik]
wenn der iran in den nachrichten ist
muss ich oft an jenen jahreswechsel
denken als sie mit reportern wie mir im
iran waren
haben sie persönlich mit ihnen
gesprochen und gefragt wie sie und
insbesondere der schah die dinge sehen
der steht im kontakt mit seiner
opposition und strebt eine breitere
basis für seine regierung an er arbeitet
auf demokratische prinzipien und
gesellschaftlichen wandel hin weshalb er
wird stark in der kritik steht wir
unterstützen ihn natürlich
was bedeutet unterstützung in diesem
fall nach dem ende des vietnamkriegs
wird der schall gestürzt sind unsere
ölversorgung wie auch die israels sowie
saudi arabien und der ganze golf in
gefahr
die revolution ist da
toller rumäne ist ein symbol der
ehrlichkeit der großartigste mann den
ich kenne
ich folge ihm denn er will den iran an
das iranische volk zurückgeben
der hass der massen auf den chart traf
im oktober auch die usa
oktober
iran grenzt im norden an die sowjetunion
entlang der grenze stehen amerikanische
station
dass die trotz der geiselnahme in der
botschaft in teheran und der schlechten
beziehungen fließt weiter iranisches öl
in die usa
der krieg begann 1980 als reaktion auf
zwei ereignisse zum einen die islamische
revolution und der sturz des schahs
sowie zum anderen die sowjetische
invasion in afghanistan
im sommer 1979 wo der präsident carter
klar dass er sich anstrengen würde
müssen damit die amerikanische
bevölkerung ihm eine zweite amtszeit
gewählt
an weihnachten dem 51 tag der
geiselnahme im iran viele sowjetunion in
afghanistan ein in dieser verschneiden
nacht wendet sich präsident carter an
die nation
ich muss über die äußerst wichtige und
instabile lage in südwestasien in
kenntnis setzen
massive sowjetische militär verbände
sind im kleinen unabhängigen staates
afghanistan eingefangen
diese invasion ist eine große gefahr für
den frieden
da von dort eine sowjetische expansion
in benachbarte länder südwest asiens
droht
ein sowjetisch besetzten afghanistan
bedroht mit iran und pakistan einen
großteil der weltweiten ölversorgung
militärberater in afghanistan fördern
die dortige marxistische regierung und
den bürgerkrieg
im iran herrscht chaos im indischen
ozean kann sowjetische kriegsschiff und
in südjemen dient die kommunistische
regierung den sowjets als brückenkopf
land und dem a witness news team
[Musik]
nach den sechs uhr nachrichten schalten
wir in wenigen minuten live ins kapitol
sie den kater vor dem kongress und dem
landesweiten fernsehpublikum die
alljährliche rede zur lage der nation
halten wird
der präsident der vereinigten staaten
[Applaus]
sehen wir heute
mit sicherheit trank er mag es nicht so
nennen doch wir werden es tun
der präsident wird russland sagen dass
jegliche beeinflussung oder invasion der
golfstaaten von den usa militärisch
beantwortet werden
jeder versuch externer kräfte die
kontrolle über die golfregion zu
erlangen wird als angriff auf
essentielle interessen der vereinigten
staaten von amerika betrachtet
einen solchen angriff werden wir mit
allen mitteln auch militärischen
zurückschlagen
vor 1980 gab es nirgends in der
islamischen welt eine amerikanische
militärpräsenz es gab keine kriegspläne
keine stützpunkte es gab keine abkommen
hinzu überflugrechten wir waren nicht
auf kämpfte am persischen golf
vorbereitet
zum ersten mal entsenden die usa
streitkräfte in diesem fall 1800
marinesoldaten an den persischen golf um
eine sowjetische expansion über
afghanistan hinaus zu unterbinden
die neue realität des öls schwenkte die
stimmung im land vorn nie mehr vietnam
zu nie mehr wert namen aber
[Musik]
jimmy carter war der am wenigsten
militär begeisterte präsident der
jüngeren geschichte und setzte dennoch
die sicherheits bürokratie in gang die
die usa auf einen krieg in der region
vorbereitet
hatte nicht vorgesehen was kommen würde
aber er setzt
die entscheidung den flugzeugträger
constellation in indischen ozean zu
entsenden ist zeugnis eines politischen
richtungswechsels
[Musik]
zum schutz der arabischen halbinsel und
des öls
[Musik]
weil der erste ernsthafte amerikanische
militäreinsatz nach der erklärung der
charta doktrinen
mann wollte mit den streitkräften die im
iran als geiseln genommenen amerikaner
retten
das war ein völliger fehlschlag
während der chaotischen flucht
bespritzten die amerikanischen soldaten
jede flugzeuge mit treibstoff und
schossen auf einige von ihnen 3 fingen
feuer und brannten vollkommen ab in zwei
blieben unversehrt einer der intakten
helikopter enthielt waffen munition
sanitäts turn und funkausrüstung
es war die größte demütigung der
regierung un charta
nun obliegt es weiterhin der iranischen
regierung die sicherheit und die baldige
freilassung der amerikanischen geiseln
zu veranlassen
rückblickend glaube ich dass es viel
leichter im zeichen von gott sein sollte
dass wir nicht der idee verfallen
sollten das us militär könnte das
problem lösen
das konnte es nicht
[Musik]
saudi arabien teilt unsere ziele
ihre energieversorgung ist für den
wohlstand vieler länder unerlässlich
sie produzieren öl für die ganze welt
vielleicht mehr als gut für sie wäre
[Musik]
dieses verantwortungsvolle selbstlose
handeln
er rettete die weltwirtschaft wohl
großen störungen und besänftigte die
ängste infolge des steigenden ölpreises
ich komme nicht umhin zu sagen dass die
zukunft saudi arabiens und die zukunft
amerikas
untrennbar miteinander verwoben sind
[Musik]
mit freundlicher unterstützung von
capital bank dem globalen technik bau
und rohstoffunternehmen flur
und ford qualität an erster stelle
[Musik]
büffel begaß ist der persische golf der
hier in der region arabische golf heißt
kuwait katar bahrain die vereinigten
arabischen emirate und oman
diese länder sind für ihr öl bekannt und
für die prekäre nähe zu den kriegen ihre
nachbarstaaten
darüber hinaus was die allgemeinheit
wenig über diese länder
ja 1498 kurz nach dem kolumbus nach
amerika segelte sandte der könig
portugals seinen admiral albuquerque aus
um den golf zu erobern so begann eine
zeit europäischer herrschaft die den
golf nachhaltig veränderte die
portugiesischen kräfte griffen
küstenstädte an und der oberleitung die
stadt muskat die albuquerque plündern
und niederbrennen ließ und den
überlebenden ohren und nasen abschnitt
[Musik]
bald darauf kam das empire
nach dem zweiten weltkrieg verschwanden
die großen imperien der welt
die herrschaft der weißen über
nichtweiße galt nicht mehr als legitim
da man hier die britische herrschaft
man könnte das gefühl hast
wir hatten uns nicht gewünscht von einer
ausländischen regierung beherrscht zu
werden
die unsere geschicke lenkt und unser
schicksal gestaltet
bei den verhandlungen zum us
militäreinsatz in der region mussten wir
auf ihre wünsche eingehen
diese länder waren erst kürzlich
unabhängig geworden und wollten keine
große militärische präsenz amerikas in
ihrer nähe
die us-regierung rief eine neue militär
institution ins leben um die sicherheit
einer wichtigen regionen der welt zu
machen
central command
für alle aktivitäten des us militärs in
jener region zuständig
ist für die interessen der usa und
unserer verbündeten unerlässlich dass
das öl ungestört aus dem golf fließen
kann
wir setzen amerikanische truppen einem
risiko aus sollte russland oder ein
anderer feind sich mit den vereinigten
staaten messen wollen werden sie die
gelegenheit dazu bekommen wir setzen
ihnen eine beachtliche streitmacht
entgegen die ihnen sehr schaden wird
politisch wünschen sich unsere
gastgeberländer dass wir keine
dauerhafte militärpräsenz einrichten
wir arbeiten über den horizont hinweg
lassen also unsere truppen und die
einsatzleitung vom gastgeberland
einladen
und ziehen dann nach abschluss der
mission wieder schnellstmöglich in die
usa ab
das us central command erforderte dass
die truppen nicht im land sondern
jenseits des horizonts verblieben
es geht dabei vollkommen um abschreckung
es ist keine besatzungsarmee oder
intervention streitmacht sondern eine
abschreckung
[Musik]
es ist nancy und mir eine freude sie als
gast des amerikanischen volkes zu
empfangen
ronald reagan erbte also den öl krieg
von jimmy carter auch wenn es damals
mehr um die sicherung amerikanischen
zugangs zum persischen golf gehen
es ist kein geheimnis dass die usa den
nahen osten als essentiell erachten wir
und unsere verbündeten sind auf das öl
angewiesen von dem viel in und umkehr
land produziert wird dennoch erkennen
wir den wert unserer partnerschaft und
ihre kultur und ambitionen an
[Musik]
ich bin hier an der grenze von pakistan
und afghanistan
ein junger mudschahidin schmuggelte uns
über die grenze mutter ihn bedeutet
freiheitskämpfer oder glaubenskrieger
die mutter ihn sehen sich in einem
heiligen krieg gegen die sowjets und
sagen dass sie diesen gewinnen werden
wenn sie waffen aus der freien welt
erhalten
wer weiß sicherlich dass wir uns in
vietnam die finger verbrannt haben als
wir in einer solchen lage helfen wollten
in vietnam habt ihr euch die finger
verbrannt aber wenn ihr uns nicht helft
wird es einen ganzen leib verbrennen
die regierung karte sah die sowjetische
invasion afghanistans als chance den
sowjets ihr eigenes vietnam aufzuzwingen
jimmy carter autorisierte die
hilfeleistungen an die mutter ideen in
afghanistan
seine nachfolgerin weitete die
unterstützung aus
das hier ist hat kann
und lächeln hat
ich bin dass afghanistan dann wurde von
sowjetischen bomben verletzt meine
mutter und meine familie getötet haben
fast eine million menschen sind tot
bitte helft afghanistan weiterhin werden
wir
sieben kriegsjahren fragte die
weltöffentlichkeit sich immer noch wie
diese afghanischen geriet die
sowjetische supermacht aufhalten
[Musik]
herr mit ist schreiner im osten
afghanistans nahm seinen 15-jährigen
sohn noah gut vor vier jahren aus der
schule umgehen wie viele andere kinder
vom dorflehrer unterrichten zu lassen
wie es seit generationen üblich
als ich ein kind war im gleichen alter
wie ihr ja wenn wir unsere flagge
schnürten den gürtel enger und zogen
gegen großbritannien in den kampf
wir vertrauten unsere religion unseren
bräuchen
unserer fahne
wir ließen uns nicht von großbritanien
kaufen hirsch müssen sie raus so dass
sie nach hause gehen mussten
des amerikanischen volkes widme ich den
start der columbia der bevölkerung
afghanistans
im kontext des kalten krieges trug der
afghanistan krieg direkt zum fall der
sowjetunion und des kommunismus
in bezug auf den krieg war es hingegen
kein großartiger sieg
eine niederlage
wird aber der ursprung vieler probleme
[Applaus]
nach afghanistan
bin laden verließ den komfort saudi
arabiens um afghanistan zu führen
seine siege über die sowjets sind in
saudi arabien sehr bekannt
gorbatschow länder stern ist an eine
blutende wunde und fordert den rückzug
der 100.000 sowjetischen truppen in
afghanistan feldzug gilt als völligen
niederlage für die sowjetunion und als
tragödie für afghanistan dass seine
unabhängigkeit mit einer million toten
bezahlt
[Musik]
wird sie sagen sie würden jede art
regierung akzeptieren die sich das
afghanische volk auferlegt wurde die us
ich sage es nochmal
wir hoffen das afghanische volk kann
seine eigene regierung wählen
frei von der besatzung ausländischer
truppen
ich habe den eindruck dass der islam
sehr im mittelpunkt steht
dass es ihnen gleichgültig ist welche
art regierung es ist so lang afghanistan
sie will während sie in nicaragua auf
eine demokratie bestehen
es ist uns nicht gleichgültig ist es
nicht an uns ist zu bestimmen
vielen dank für die erhellenden fragen
[Musik]
als saddam hussein
1980 im iran ein ziel und das chaos der
islamischen revolution ausnutzen wollte
war das den politischen
entscheidungsträgern in den usa durchaus
recht
erst als der iran sich erfolgreich
wehrte und
zur bedrohung für saddam wurde
beschlossen die usa sich auf sams seite
zu schlagen und ihn zu unterstützen
ich möchte an diesem tag über
essentielle interessen des
amerikanischen folk- gesprächen die in
der golfregion auf dem spiel stehen nach
beinahe 54 monaten des aufschwungs ist
es leicht die bedeutsamkeit des
persischen golfs für die sicherheit der
nation zu vergessen doch ich denke dass
sich alle hier wie auch unsere zuhörer
der auswirkungen der ölkrise von vor
wenigen jahren bewusst sind die
zermürbenden schlangen an der tankstelle
der mangel die rationierung steigende
energiepreise
zweistellige inflation und
obdachlosigkeit
erschütterten unsere wirtschaft in ihren
grundfesten die
usa beteiligten sich an diesem krieg da
die regierung befürchtete der iran
könnte sich durchsetzen
also gaben wir saddam hussein
informationen halfen bei der bewaffnung
und lieferten so genannte mehrzweck
technologien die hubschrauber lastwagen
und computer
schulz traf den irakischen außenminister
tarik asis um über einen un
waffenstillstand am golf zu sprechen
hier geht es nach unten
es ist kaum zu glauben aber die usa
lieferten unter ronald reagan während
sie zeitgleich saddam gegen die
ayatollahs unterstützten waffen an
iranische kräfte damit diese ihnen
halfen amerikanische geiseln im libanon
im rahmen der sogenannten iran contra
affäre zu befreien
im tausch gegen die familien geforderten
waffen hoffen die usa auf die freiheit
der amerikanischen geiseln in beirut
an diesem punkt des iran-irak-krieges
unterstützen die usa beide
kriegsparteien
sams und mündete im angriff auf die uss
tag
zwei exozet raketen trafen die stars
eine durchschlug sie die andere erzeugte
eine fürchterliche explosion
sei dann bezeichnete den angriff als
unfall und bot eine entschuldigung und
entschädigung für die opfer
vertreter der usa nahmen die irakische
erklärung an es wäre ein tragischer
unfall gewesen
da beide staaten auf exporte angewiesen
waren nahm der irak iranische tanker ins
visier was der iran natürlich ebenso
erwidert
unser aufenthaltsraum ist oben das hier
war aber schon immer der speisesaal
tanker aus kuwait ins visier gerieten
bat der kuwaitische ihm ihr die usa um
schutz für seine tankerflotte
ich möchte noch einmal betonen dass die
usa die sicherheit kuwait und all
unserer freunde am golf garantieren
deren entschlossenheit im angesichts des
terrors seitens des irans
bewundernswertes
am ende für die kuwaitische tankerflotte
unter anderer flagge
der usa
innerhalb von sieben stunden geleiteten
drei us kriegsschiffe zwei kuwaitische
tanker unter amerikanischer flagge durch
die besonders gefährliche straße von
hormus
vergessen sie niemals der iran wird
nicht über die nutzung des persischen
golfs entscheiden
die schwachen ohne entschlossenheit und
stärke sehen dass öle als werkzeug als
waffe um amerika zu schaden und
konflikte und gewalt im nahen osten wie
auch auf der ganzen welt anzustechen
nicht
sind unsere schiffe wirklich sicher
sie werden uns in einen krieg im nahen
osten verwickeln
im vergleich zu us navy war die
iranische marine klein jedoch war sie in
der lage den persischen golf zu verminen
[Musik]
die iranische platzierung von minen in
internationalen gewässern machte und
sprachlos
minen sind ungezählte waffen
sie wissen nicht unter welcher flagge
ein schiff fährt dass auch sie aufläuft
das pentagon hält angesichts der
iranischen drohungen den atem an bald
darauf begann die us navy mit der
eskorte kuwaitischer tanker
eines der kriegsschiffe traf eine mine
das dient er als vorwand für weitere
eskalation geben sie alarm
aufgeregt station
als reaktion zerstörte ein
flugzeugträger flottenverband iranische
kanonenboote und eine ölplattform
[Musik]
ministerpräsident könnten sie noch mal
aus 15 metern heran kommen
dann sind wir fertig wir bleiben derweil
hier
du sollst jetzt nicht fressen im kilt
sehr gut
mehr
[Musik]
am ende des iran irak krieges war saddam
hussein quasi bankrott
er schuldete kuwait milliarden dollar
er sagte zu ihnen er habe im iran für
sie gekämpft für all seine arabischen
brüdern also wäre es nur gerecht ihm die
schulden zu erlassen
also viel saddam hussein in kuwait ein
am anfang meiner amtszeit versuchten wir
den waffenstillstand zwischen iran und
irak sowie unsere beziehungen zum irak
zu stärken
adams kalkül dass er cool white
ungestraft annektieren könne fußte auf
seinem verständnis der einstellung der
usa gegenüber dem iran er sah uns als
freunde als verbündete
er dachte wohl er könnte gewalt einfach
einnehmen und dann durch diskussionen
und verhandlungen kuwait einen
eigenständigen staat teil der arabischen
liga und der vereinten nationen wenn die
neunzehnte provinz verwandten
in drei tagen schaffte der irak 120.000
soldaten und 850 panzer nach kuwait in
richtung der saudischen grenze im süden
angesichts dieser eindeutigen
eskalierenden bedrohung hat könig fahrt
von saudi arabien unserem unterstützung
zum ersten mal seit der einrichtung des
us central command wurde der dort nach
und nach entwickelt die kriegs plan
umgesetzt
willkommen bei air force nach blaue
neuigkeiten diesem monat die luftbrücke
der operation desert shield war ein
erfolg und transportiert dem mehr
menschen und ausrüstung schneller und
weiter als je zuvor
der einsatz ist hoch der irak ist ein
reiches mächtiges land mit den
zweitgrößten ölreserven der welt und
über einer million bewaffneter soldaten
das viertgrößte militär der welt
unser land bezieht fast die hälfte des
hier verbrauchten öls aus dem ausland
weshalb dies eine bedrohung für unsere
wirtschaftliche unabhängigkeit ist
wenn er sich hier über die grenze zu
kommen werden wir im ordentlich den
hintern versohlen
der irak kontrolliert etwa zehn prozent
der bekannten ölreserven auf der welt
gemeinsam mit kuwait sogar das doppelte
ich kann nicht abschätzen wie lange es
dauern wird bis sich der iraker aus
kuwait zurückzieht
sanktionen entfalten ihre wirkung erst
mit der zeit
wir halten uns weiter alle optionen mit
unseren verbündeten offen in keinem fall
werden wir jedoch diese aggression
dulden
der zweck von centcom hatte sich
grundlegend gewandelt
anfangs wollte man einen sowjetischen
einmarsch in der region verhindern die
so wichtig für amerika war
nun wollte man eine feindliche nation
innerhalb der region davon abhalten sie
zu dominieren
es geht nicht um ein kleines lange
sondern eine neue weltordnung hier muss
die phrasierung stimmen so etwa
verschiedene nationen mitgeteilt im ziel
universelle streben der menschheit
frieden sicherheit freiheit und recht
eine welt die unsere kinder würdig ist
die staatengemeinschaft verurteilt ist
die eine pause ja ich wollte immer
sicherstellen dass niemand glaubt diese
welt wäre das opfer unserer kinder wert
sondern unserer kinder würdig
sicherheit freiheit und recht eine welt
die unsere kinder würdig ist
wir müssen sicherstellen dass kein
tyrann den großteil aller reserven
kontrollieren kann es ist ein
[Musik]
im august sprachen sie von öl und das
amerikanische arbeitsplätze und unsere
lebensweise in gefahr sein
im wahlkampf war das öl plötzlich kein
thema mehr sie sagten die demonstranten
würden nicht verstehen dass es bei dem
krieg nicht ums öl ging das war jedoch
eines der von ihnen genannten nationalen
interessen ist das nicht länger ein
grund für unser eingreifen es spielt
eine rolle aber es ist nicht einer der
hauptgründe
meine damen und herren der präsident und
die first lady
[Musik]
es war und ist nicht unsere
energieversorgung unsere wirtschaftliche
stabilität und die stabilität der region
die auf dem spiel steht sondern die
aussicht auf frieden in der zeit nach
dem kalten krieg das eine neue
weltordnung des rechts
[Applaus]
dafür am ende hatten wir einen krieg mit
dem ziel die irakische armee aus kuwait
zu vertreiben in der hoffnung gar der
erwartung dass eine militärische
niederlage zum sturz von saddam hussein
führen würde
dieses eine grosse armee vereinter
streitkräfte panzer transporter
luftabwehrgeschütze unsere strategie ist
einfach wir fangen sie ab dann töten wir
sie
es wird nicht wie panama sein ein
glorreicher feld zu es wird ein langer
blutiger krieg
[Musik]
wir verzeichnen jeden tag 1000 gefangene
innerhalb von 24 stunden
anfangs strebten wir etwa 400 bis 500 an
das war unser idealwert
jetzt erreichen wir das doppelte und
sind sehr glücklich darüber
sie wurden durchsucht und sind jetzt in
einem alter blog in dem 50 bis 100
gefangene gleichzeitig verzeichnet
werden können hier beginnt die erfassung
wir sind noch dabei alles einzurichten
damit sie die schritte nacheinander
durchlaufen können die aktuell
vorgesehen sind
ich zeige ihnen eine unserer acht
verpflegungs anlagen die wir
eingerichtet haben um 3.000 bis 4.000
kriegsgefangene am tag ernähren zu
können
vielen dank für ihr interesse an der
firma
[Applaus]
unsere truppen kämpften ehrenhaft und
befreiten kuwait
kuwait ist frei die irakische armee
besiegt
unsere militärischen ziele erreicht
[Musik]
auch der satz zum beklagte präsident
george herbert walker bush dass es kein
sauberes ende gegeben habe
saddam hussein war nach wie vor an der
macht
die sanktionen der vereinigten nationen
gegen den irak müssen weiter bestehen
bis bagdad eine neue führung hat die in
frieden mit ihren nachbarn und ihrem
volk koexistieren will
adam schlug einen aufstand irakische
schiiten und kurden nieder die
us-truppen sahen zu
diesmal bei erfolglos
unser korrespondent berichtet vom
arabischen golf
da sich der irak nicht an die un
resolution hält entsendet präsident bush
koalitionstruppen in den südlichen irak
für saudi arabien und kuwait stellte
saddam immer noch die größte gefahr dar
also fasste die regierung unter bush den
folgenreichen beschluss dauerhaft
us-truppen in der region zu stationieren
[Musik]
meine amerikanischen mitbürger ich muss
ihnen von einem irakischen angriff auf
die vereinigten staaten berichten
vergangenen april deckte die regierung
bereits ein versuchtes bomben attentat
auf präsident george bush während seines
besuchs von kuwait stadt auf
die usa führten täglich patrouillenflüge
über dem norden und süden des irak durch
heute wie sich angriffe unserer
streitkräfte auf militärische ziele im
irak an
regelmäßig werden irakische
militäranlagen angegriffen und niemand
interessiert sich dafür
es ging darum saddam einzudämmen und die
stabilität und ordnung in der region zu
wahren
tatsächlich beförderte das den
terrorismus gegen die vereinigten
staaten mit dem ziel die usa zum
völligen abzug ihrer truppen zu zwingen
wir riefen einen dschihad gegen die
ungerechte verbrecherische und iranische
regierung der vereinigten staaten aus
er war es islamischen und patriotischen
gründen gegen die anwesenheit
ausländischer truppen in saudi arabien
zum einen sollte sein heimatland nicht
von fremden streitkräften besetzt sein
und
zum anderen waren nicht muslimische
drucken nach mekka und medina den
heiligsten stätten des islam nicht
willkommen
bin laden und andere seien die
erfolgreiche vertreibung der sowjets aus
afghanistan als beleg dafür es auch mit
der anderen supermacht aufnehmen zu
können
nur sie könnten die andere supermacht
aus der islamischen welt vertreiben
der lastwagen stand verdächtig nahe am
sperrbereich als er explodierte die
explosion war fast 200 kilometer weit zu
hören
bezüglich des schrecklichen angriffs
gestern auf amerikaner in saudi arabien
habe ich folgendes zu sagen wir werden
nicht ruhen bis die schuldigen gefunden
sind
und so erklärte bin laden den
vereinigten staaten von amerika den
krieg es war kein geheimnis clintons
reaktion blieb wirkungslos
eine explosion kostete heute morgen
mindestens vier mannschaftsmitglieder
der uss cole das leben
der terrorismus ist eine der größten
gefahren dieser globalisierten er
heute schlagen wir zurück
die morgen griffen die usa in
afghanistan einen der aktivsten
terroristen stützpunkte der welt unter
der leitung von gruppen in verbindung
mit osama bin laden an
heute wie sich unsere streitkräfte an
terroristen anlagen im irak und sudan
anzugreifen
militärisch war clinton ein
aktivistischer präsident
militärisch und politisch war er aber
ein aktivistischer präsident der nichts
erreicht
welche botschaft würden sie einen
präsident clinton richten
menschen wird der name clinton ruft
abscheu und ekel hervor das herz des
präsidenten dass die ermordung hunderter
kinder zulässt kennt keine sprache unser
volk in arabien wird die botschaft ohne
worte an ihn richten da er wollte nicht
versteht
liga
[Musik]
die vereinigten staaten waren vom norden
bis in den süden vom westen bis in den
osten gelähmt von angst und schrecken
[Musik]
ja
ich schwöre beim allmächtigen gott der
den himmel ohne seine hob dass die
vereinigten staaten sich keine
sicherheit gewiss sein können bis die
armeen der ungläubigen das land
muhammads verlassen haben
[Musik]
der elfte september
überraschte diese regierung selbst
erklärter experten vollkommen
terrorismus wird nicht gegen unser land
bestehen
ich bitte meine schweigeminute
dort stabil bush hatte die undankbare
aufgabe dem volk zu erklären was
passiert war wieso es passiert war und
warum es nie wieder geschehen würde
mit jeder kreuzfahrt hoffen sie amerika
in angst zu versetzen dass wir uns aus
der welt zurückziehen und unsere freunde
im stich lassen sie hassen unsere
freiheiten für die freiheit der religion
freiheit der rede die freiheit zu wählen
sich zu versammeln und einander zu
widersprechen heute richten die
vereinigten staaten von amerika folgende
forderungen an die taliban
liefern sie alle al kaida führer aus die
sich in ihrem land verstecken
die forderungen die die regierung bush
nach dem 11 september an die damals
herrschenden taliban richtete waren
durchaus angemessen
gibt uns die verschwörer und garantiert
uns dass ihr antiamerikanischen
terroristen keine zuflucht gewähren
werde
sie lehnten die forderungen ab
im krieg gegen die taliban bekannt vor
einer woche die bombardierung
afghanistans
es ist schwierig einen überblick zu
bekommen glücklicherweise befindet sich
unser reporter diese woche auf einer von
den taliban organisierten reise nach
kandahar
waren stets in begleitung junger
wohlgesonnener und schwer bewaffneter
taliban soldaten schliefen in
gästehäusern und hatten einen koch der
einen arm im kampf gegen russland
verloren hatte
alle von menschen auf der straße bis zu
hochrangigen anführern lehnten eine
auslieferung bin ladens ab wir sind
nicht bereit einen muslim an ausländer
auszuliefern insbesondere an amerikaner
die in diesem moment unser unschuldiges
volk ermorden
wir mussten die taliban stürzen nicht
aber danach für fast zwei jahrzehnte in
afghanistan bleiben
die us-behörden zufolge sei der sturz
der taliban nur eine frage der zeit auch
wenn es länger dauert als erwartet
obwohl das pentagon videos von präzision
schlägen veröffentlicht ist die
regierung nicht mit dem verlauf des
krieges zufrieden
ein ehemaliger sowjetischer fliegerhorst
könnte als basis für us operationen in
afghanistan dienen
oberhalb der tora bora höhen dem letzten
versteck von al kaida und vielleicht
ihres anführers osama bin laden
erschienen gewaltige feuerbälle
auf unserem weg warf eine b 52 ihre
bomben in richtung tora bora nach einem
aufstieg von drei kilometern fanden in
einem dorf 15 zerstörte häuser einen
wachhund der nichts bewachte und den
gestank des todes in der luft
weil sie sich zu sehr aus diente
etwas versucht das wir nicht hätten tun
sollen afghanistan zu befrieden
bin laden versuchte mit seinem krieg
gegen die vereinigten staaten scheinbar
sie zum gleichen fehler zu vermeiden
die amerikaner haben die geschichte
vergessen und nichts von ihr gelernt
sagt dieser taliban soldat hier werden
ihre schädel in den bergen begraben
das ziel des 11 september war es nicht
die usa zu besiegen sondern sie zu
fehlern zu verleiten
die letztendlich zu einer niederlage der
vereinigten staaten für hört
sobald sie sich diese niederlage ein
stünden würde ihr rückzug bin laden den
weg ebnen damit er sein zweites ziel
erreichen und den islam an sich reinigen
könnte
diese strategie ging tatsächlich auf wir
waren in einen unnötigen nicht so
gewinnen den krieg verwittert in kabul
eroberten us marines die amerikanische
botschaft zurück seit 1989 geschlossen
wird sie wieder öffnen und eine neue ära
amerikanischer spanischer beziehungen
einläuten
liegen jedoch nachts kugeln über die
köpfe der soldaten hinweg als nächstes
werden die marines in kandahar
patroullieren der spirituellen heimat
der taliban
zu bevorstehenden einnahme des
flughafens kandahar sagte das pentagon
man werde nicht lange als
besatzungsmacht in afghanistan bleiben
vier monaten zerstörten hier die
ausbildungslager der terroristen in
afghanistan und befreiten das land von
brutaler unterdrückung
[Applaus]
kabul ist ein pulverfass geworden zwei
millionen menschen größtenteils
flüchtlinge hunderttausende waffen und
keine regierung wir gewinnen den krieg
gegen den terror
hier sieht man wie die usa auf einen
erfolg pochten
und den ist nicht geöffnet
[Musik]
werden die usa im irak so erfolgreich
sein wie in afghanistan 66 prozent sagen
ja 26 nein die allgemeinheit ist
zuversichtlich dass die usa es schaffen
können einer umfrage von letzter woche
zufolge denken 78% wir sollten den irak
angreifen der präsident kann hier die
führung übernehmen und mit der richtigen
strategie viel erreichen
bush und sein umfeld vizepräsident
cheney verteidigungsminister rumsfeld
und sein stellvertreter rolf eriksson im
irak nicht eine gefahr sondern eine
chance
um die netzwerke zu bekämpfen sollten
wir ihre verstecke ausreichen und auch
jene bekämpfen die terroristen
beherbergen
sie waren dem irrglauben aufgesessen den
irak in eine pro-westliche liberale
demokratie zu verwandeln wäre eine
leichte aufgabe und
das wiso mit im irak eine basis für
einen weit reichenden wandels schaffen
könnten
sie bewarben den irak krieg indem sie
saddam hussein als personifiziertes übel
darstellten jemanden der
massenvernichtungswaffen habe und diese
ohne mit der wimper zu zucken an
al-qaida geben würde
wir alle wissen dass das unsinn
wadan hatte nichts mit dem 11 september
zu tun und hatte keine
massenvernichtungswaffen und noch nicht
einmal ein großes entwicklungsprogramm
für sie
sie sollten mit ihrer aufgabe fortfahren
so ein zahn brother ein menschenleben
ist ein menschenleben wenn ihnen
menschenleben am herzen liegen heben sie
das im balco auf
das kann ich nicht ich bin nur ein
techniker
ich bin auch techniker aber das wäre
mein fasten
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das sind die fakten auf basis
unumstößlicher beweise keine
spekulationen die wohl dokumentierte
wahrheit
ich halte die fakten die zu dieser
schicksalsträchtigen abstimmung führten
für über jeden zweifel erhaben
wenn wir nicht einschreiten wird saddam
hussein sei national an biologischen und
chemischen waffen ausweiten und
versuchen atomwaffen zu entwickeln
zurück zur operation
der krieg gegen saddam hussein hat
begonnen
das weiße haus gab bekannt der präsident
würde in einer rede erklären die
entwaffnung des iraks sei nun im gang
unsere streitkräfte stehen am anfang
einer militäroperationen die in irak zu
entwaffnen sein volk zu befreien und die
welt vor einer großen gefahr zu schützen
direkt vor uns wurden mindestens zehn
große gebäude in nur zwei minuten
zerstört
es ist unglaublich wie in einem
actionfilm aber das hier ist real es ist
schockierend
das waren 30 bis 40 tools mit eis
ein gebäude nach dem anderen fällt sie
jagen ganze gebäude mit den raketen in
die luft
saddam hatte das westufer in den letzten
20 jahren aufbau lassen wir sehen das
gerade alles verschwinden
man war überzeugt eine demonstration der
militärischen überlegenheit amerikas
nicht nur der macht sondern der
übermacht amerikas der fähigkeit und
auch des willens schnell und effizient
einen klaren sieg zu erringen würde die
ganze region verändern
wenn wir ehrlich sind nach sechs wochen
dachten sie sie es geschafft der irak
krieg wäre vorbei und sie könnten sich
ihr nächstes ziel suchen
sie wollen die regierung übernehmen das
lassen wir nicht zu ich bin jetzt die
regierung niemand samstag wir haben den
krieg gewonnen und dieses volk erobert
also muss ich mich jetzt um sie kümmern
stellt mir gerne fragen wenn ich die
antwort nicht weiß denke ich mir was aus
wir wollen frei sein
nicht nur von saddam befreit sondern
auch von amerika
im april 2003 übernahm das 82 sste
fallschirmspringer regiment eine schule
in falludscha für eine
infanteriekompanie
solange die soldaten da waren konnte es
dort keinen unterricht geben bieten die
iraker protestierten gegen die
amerikanische besatzung warfen steine
es gab anti amerikanische sprechchöre
irgendwann fiel ein schuss niemand weiß
von wem
daraufhin eröffneten die us soldaten das
feuer töteten so mehr als ein dutzend
iraker und verletzten dutzende mehr
auf amerikanischer seite gab es keine
verluste
wie beim massaker von posten 1770 nur
dass amerika diesmal die brücke und der
irak die patrioten stellte die keine
ausländischen truppen in ihrer stadt
wollten
[Musik]
seit er die guten
mehr briten sind gute leute
willkommen
für die menschen im irak war die aussage
man wolle freiheit bringen schwer zu
glauben
begriffe wie anglo englisch oder british
stehe nicht für befreien
sondern für unterdrückung manipulation
und ausbeutung
der menschen die vier nicht dass sie mit
den usa zusammen arbeiteten jede nacht
schossen sie mit raketen und mörsern auf
die bunker man musste sich erst mal
daran gewöhnen die nach dem beschuss und
das feuerwerk zu erleben
ist das jetzt besser viel besser seit
wir die kontrolle über gaben habe ich
das gefühl dass die menschen auf der
straße sich mit dem gedanken
angefreundet haben das wir irland nicht
übernehmen sondern helfen wollen
nachrichten zur operation iraqi freedom
mit hilfe der koalition nahmen irakische
sicherheitskräfte der sieben
aufständische fest die bei zwei
angriffen auf die hauptstadt morde
begangen hatten zudem wurden zwei
aufständische festgenommen die irakische
bürger entführt hatten die
koalitionstruppen geholfen hatten andere
verhaftungen betrafen waffenhandel und
die unterstützung ausländischer
kombattanten
die erste riege us-befehlshaber die mit
der besatzung des iraks betraut war
wartete darauf dass repressionen zur
unterwerfung führen würden
ich bin
was du dir gerade fertiggestellt
wir sind mit den erdarbeiten für eine
verwahrungs anlage für 2009 fertig
wir gehen davon aus dass wir gefangene
haben werden also brauchen wir einen ort
an dem wir sie festhalten können
dreifache stacheldraht nach
militärstandard soll sie am ausbruch
hindern
für alle gefangenen die wir heute abend
machen
genauer weiß ich es auch nicht
die us-truppen sperrten tausende ein oft
mit fadenscheiniger begründung
doch die gefängnisse wurden zu
brutstätten für aufständische
sie einzufangen und einzusperren machte
wie so oft alles noch schlimmer
das bin ich das auch davon
wir sollten uns ausziehen und wir sagten
dass gegen den islam dann schlugen sie
auf uns ein
us-politiker und befehlshaber
gleichermaßen stellten unsere ziele als
wohltätig und erleuchtet da
wir würden den irak zu einer besseren
heimat für iraker machen die bilder von
abu ghraib machten klar dass das eine
lüge war
im irak beginnt eine neue ära irland es
nicht länger in den fängen eines
brutalen diktators
denn amerikanische politiker
expansionspläne schmieden reden sie nur
selten offener über viel lieber reden
sie über die mission amerikas freiheit
und demokratie zu verbreiten so tarnen
sie den imperialismus und machen ihn
beim amerikanischen volk salonfähig beim
amerikanischen militäreinsatz am
persischen golf ging es nie um freiheit
werden
es ging um öl und vorherrschaft
der albtraum saddam hussein wird bald
vorbei sein
erfolg kann als erbe einer großartigen
zivilisation zum wohle der menschheit
beitragen
sie haben besseres verdient als tyrannei
korruption und folterkammern
erfolg verdient ein leben in freiheit
ich versichere allen bürgern des iraks
dass irland bald frei sein wird
es ist schon cool draußen von einer
traube kinder umringt zu werden
sie fragen danach süßigkeiten
die frage nach geld oder auch stiften
sie nehmen gerne alles was die soldaten
abgeben können
so werden wir letztendlich gewinnen
die erwachsenen haben bereits
entschieden welchen weg sie wählen
wollen aber die kinder der nächsten
generation werden verstehen dass wir
hier sind um ihnen zu helfen
sie werden letztendlich die demokratie
begreifen
[Musik]
am 8 november begann operation algier
auf bitten des irakischen premier
jadallah wie und seiner interviews
regierung
dass marin chor und teile der us armee
griffen die unterwanderte stadt
falludscha an die in vergangenen monaten
viele anti irakischen aufständischen und
freiheitskämpfern als zuflucht diente
in den usa wird darüber gestritten wer
hier bekämpfen kämpfen wir gegen reste
von saddam regime terroristen und
dschihadisten die von außen kommen
oder ist es die irakische bevölkerung
die sich gegen die besatzung wird
anfangs hatten die kombattanten keinen
kampf für die kämpfer denen wir nun hier
begegnen hingegen schon es könnte daran
liegen dass sie einer anderen
politischen gruppe oder einem anderen
stamm angehören
oder es liegt daran dass das hier die
letzte festung der aufständischen im
irak ist und sie in eine ecke gedrängt
worden
hunderte unschuldige iraker wurden mit
autobomben angegriffen darunter dutzende
sunniten beim verlassen einer moschee in
alanya
selbstmordattentäter tötete mehr als
drei dutzend studenten an der mustang
serie universität in bagdad
14 polizisten wurden letzte woche
gefesselt und mit verbundenen augen
hingerichtet der irakische vizepräsident
wurde bei einem versuchten anschlag
verletzt ist jedoch erstaunlicherweise
schon wieder an der arbeit
manchmal ignorieren die irakischen
sicherheitskräfte die angriffe auf uns
einfach oder unterstützen sie sogar
bonn
was wird gegen jene unternommen die
korrupt sind oder gegen an zu arbeiten
bei allen konflikten in der geschichte
unseres landes gab es jene die das
handtuch werfen wollten
sie sagen es klappt nicht
es war schon im unabhängigkeitskrieg so
george washington wäre beinahe gefeuert
worden es wird interessant sein zu sehen
wie historiker diese periode in 20 bis
30 jahren einschätzen werden
einen sohn oder eine tochter zu grabe zu
tragen ist für eltern und denkbar letzte
woche wurde das undenkbare in horb ohl
realität der tag brachte die bevölkerung
zusammen um gemeinsam zu trauern
vor der kirche san nancy und andrew base
mit zehn ihr dabei zu wie der mit
flaggen verhöhnte sarg ihres sohnes den
weg auf den nahen friedhof begann
ich war unglaublich stolz auf meinen
sohn und seine entscheidung seinem land
dienen zu wollen
auf alles was er tat
es als meine verantwortung gegenüber die
wahrheit zu sagen so wie ich sie
verstand
das gibt es schwarz auf weiß von mir bei
einer präsidentschaft obamas habe ich
hoffnung dass wir unseren fokus auf
militärische macht überdenken könnten
[Applaus]
er hat sein versprechen gehalten und
euch aus dem irak nach hause gebracht
präsident obamas wahlkampf stützte sich
auf zwei versprechungen zum einen würde
er bei einer wahl den irak krieg
verantwortungsvoll beendet
dank ihnen und ihre alle anstrengungen
können wir diesen krieg nun beenden
zum anderen würde er bei einer wahl den
krieg in afghanistan gewinnen den er für
nötig hält es ist für unser land
unerlässlich weitere 30.000 soldaten
nach afghanistan zu schicken
ich würde hier gerne nachfragen wenn wir
abziehen hinterlassen wir ein land in
dem al qaida frei handeln trainieren und
stützpunkte unterhalten kann
ist das keine bedrohung
wir sollten möglichkeiten in erwägung
ziehen wie wir das ohne die fortwährende
präsenz zehntausender us soldaten
verhindern können
[Musik]
zur einrichtung einer flugverbotszone
über libyen
gegen das gaddafi regime in libyen zu
ende auch hier war militärisches
eingreifen unerlässlich um eine
situation zu erschaffen in der das
libysche volk seine zukunft selbst in
die hand nehmen kann
mindestens 3000 menschen starben letztes
jahr bei dem versuch europa über das
mittelmeer zu erreichen sie wissen die
windigen boote der schleuser hielten der
sie nicht stand
ich habe deutlich gemacht dass ich
jederzeit bereit bin und sein militär
entschlossen einzusetzen wenn es
erforderlich ist
darum verfolgen wir al qaida in die
letzten winkel
obama wollte die methoden aufgeben die
erfolglos blieben nicht die politik
überdenken sondern nur den krieg mit
anderen methoden fortsetzen
anstatt auf invasionen setzten wir
stärker auf luftschläge und drohnen
angriffe
so ging es das amerikanische volk nichts
mehr an
der irak zerfällt angesichts der
terror-organisation isis die mit mossul
nun die zweitgrösste stadt des iraks
kontrolliert kaluza und ramadi in sowie
teile von
[Musik]
roger und tikrit
trotz zahlenmäßiger unterlegenheit
überwältigten sie die irakische armee
von der viele ihre uniformen von sich
rissen und flohen
bei der wahl präsident obamas hatten wir
erwartet ihn bestnoten geben zu können
wir erinnern uns bei seiner
amtseinführung erhielt er den
friedensnobelpreis
er hat keine bestnoten verdient
schneidet höchstens mehr sichern
warum sollten wir uns angesichts unserer
probleme für den irak interessieren im
irak geht es um wichtige interessen der
usa zum einen die bekämpfung von al
qaida zum anderen die versorgung des
globalen marktes mit energieträgern bis
2035 wird der irak 45% des
gesamtzuwachses der ölexporte ausmachen
verfällt der irak in einen bürgerkrieg
hätte das ernste auswirkungen auf unsere
heimische wirtschaft
guten tag
es freut mich wieder an der national
defence university sprechen zu können
können sie den toten sagen ihre leben
werden so viel wert die unsere können
sie denn die drohnen entziehen
können sie die angriffe auf basis
verdächtige aktivitäten einstellen wir
arbeiten daran
anfang 2015 erhielt ich eine mail mit
einer einladung ins oval office
ich hielte es für einen witz war es aber
nicht
ich kam ins oval office und wir aßen zum
mitteilen
er hatte meine bücher entweder gelesen
oder war über sie informiert worden
ich hatte eine liste an empfehlungen
vorbereitet
ich empfahl eine ernsthafte untersuchung
des ursprungs unserer kriege und unseres
verhaltens
ich sprach über unsere freiwilligenarmee
warum war die bevölkerung amerikas vom
krieg so abgeschottet
die antwort ist einfach
wenn man sich nicht freiwillig zum
dienst meldet bleibt man selbst und
seine familie von diesen kriegen fällig
um bereit
all points er entgegnete zu all meinen
argumenten aber
das geht nicht weil
am ende folgerte ich das selbst wenn ein
präsident wie obama über den tellerrand
hinaus schauen wollte
und ernsthaft andere stimmen anhören
wollte
es wohl keine auswirkungen haben würde
wenn ich das openoffice also nach einer
stunde wieder verlassen und ist sein
team immer noch
der kongress ist immer noch da die new
york times die washington post und nbc
news sind immer noch da
ihre präsenz er lebt den präsidenten
seine schranken auf
während meiner amtszeit zerstörte ich
zerstörten mir alle gemeinsam das
kalifat
jetzt sollen die länder der region
selbst ihre grenzen schützen
wir sind nicht mehr ihre polizei
behalten aber dass das öl behalten wir
jetzt ist unsere torheit offensichtlich
geworden ein weiterer präsident warb
damit unsere truppen abzuziehen nur um
dann den krieg fortzusetzen diesmal
sogar ohne vorgeschobene kohärente
strategie
wir handelten vergangene nacht um einen
krieg zu beenden
wir führen diesen krieg nun seit 40
jahren weil wir glauben dass unser leben
vom zugang zum öl abhängt
gegen die bevölkerung vor ort die
politisch nicht von uns dominiert werden
möchte eine power packs
wenn sich jemand für meinen einsatz
bedankt ignoriere ich es einfach es ist
nervig
bei soldaten im aktiven dienst leuten
dabei die alarmierten
wenn ich einen soldaten für seinen
einsatz danken
will ich mich selbst dabei gut fühlen
ein making-of ich gebe vor eine
verantwortung wahrzunehmen
ich habe mich bedankt und die
verantwortung erfüllt weshalb ich weiter
voller tugend meinem tagwerk nachgehen
kann feeling futures
als bürger ist es unsere verantwortung
uns ernsthaft um das wohlergehen unserer
soldaten zusagen
diese sorge existiert bei uns nicht dass
nicht alles was wir haben sind gesten
[Musik]